how's your jaw is your door okay you
nicked me in the drawer you did you did
look at the door a little bit you did
it's all about mindset
pushing yourself out your comfort zone
are you ready three two one
property but also you've signed up for a
very high profile fight I have never
boxed in my entire life 10 weeks ago I
didn't even know what a jab was
you've only been boxing the last eight
weeks but now if you take any girl off
the streets you're probably gonna mash
them up
do you make good money on any fans life
changing money I've been doing it for a
year and my first year I made 300 000.
I'm in it to win it you know what I mean
I'm not actually in it for the money and
the fame the this for that I'm generally
in it because I want to be the best
[Music]
Daniella Hemsley great to have you on
the show thank you so much you are
extremely inspirational in there you're
an entrepreneur but also you've signed
up for a very high profile fight which
is going to take place next week I am
super excited I'm ready I've been
training hard and the reason I wanted to
interview you is because you're
successful you're successful in property
you've got this fight coming up which we
have sponsored you for I have no doubt
you're going to win but why don't you
just introduce kind of how did you go
from an overweight kid growing up in
London to now being literally signing up
for fights training how many hours a
week you train 20 hours a week I'm
training yeah 15 18 hours a week you
know I'm inspired because I've got my
fight coming you have so we've been
sparring um why don't you just introduce
yourself and and why did you choose to
sign up for such a hard such a hard
thing so I'm an influencer content
creator media personality I like to call
myself I came from a place you know I
used to be mobile obese I struggled with
mental health for many many years being
you know a depressed Young little girl
no self-confidence and I decided I want
change so then I started you know a
fitness journey I lost 30 kilos in
weight I grew a massive passion for
weightlifting gained a lot of knowledge
started to inspire people online by
sharing my journey and then I got this
opportunity to do the boxing the Kingpin
high stakes tournament and you know I'm
all about putting myself out of my
comfort zone pushing myself to my limits
and for me it was a no-brainer it was an
opportunity for me to get in the best
shape of my life to inspire people and
to do a competition and win it and I'm
in it to win it so you've got three
fights coming up yeah and the prize is
how much 100 Grand it's a hundred
thousand pound prize that's a lot of
money to win yes and what will you make
money if you lose or is that only if you
win the way it works is you obviously
get a fight pass so no matter what
obviously you get paid to do it and then
every time you win your fee will go up
so my fee will go from 8 to 10 to 12 and
then when I win whole tournament I get
the 100 000 pound prize money how do you
think it relates in terms of winning a
fight and winning in Fitness you're also
an influencer you're also now in
property more recently do you think
there's a theme behind winning or do you
think that it's it's very different in
sports that it is in business I think I
think all sort of intertwines it's all
about mindset
pushing yourself out your comfort zone
learning new things you have to push
yourself to your limits and be out of
your comfort zone and it's the same with
you know property and your your partner
Akon he's a UFC champion fighter he's an
MMA world champion wow that's why he
beat me in the ring then he was a
champion you challenged him though I did
challenge you did challenge you you're
not bad I held my own at first for a
minute and then he quickly uh he quickly
got the better of me we've just been
spawned how did you find today's
borrowing with me and Akon and spying
with all the grown men I loved it you
know you're a challenge you know you
weren't you weren't an easy spa and you
definitely put pressure on me
[Music]
can you tell everybody
out of your life
dang day
is your door okay yeah man it's uh
you nicked me in the drawer you did you
did look at the jaw a little bit you did
how did this all come about then so did
they approach you or did you approach
them what happened they approached me on
Instagram they asked my books and
experience and my wakes obviously
there's a weight category
I've never boxed in my entire life so
literally 10 weeks ago I didn't even
know what a jab was I've never touched a
pad but I wanted to do it and I wanted
the challenge so I was like all for it I
said yes sign the contracts and then
yeah I've been in full-time training
camp ever since that's awesome you know
someone I heard someone once say I think
I was watching Tick Tock videos and it
came up and I thought that's a really
inspirational true thing they said if
you spend 100 hours doing something in a
year you're probably going to be the top
five percent in the world at that thing
and I thought that's so true it's like
boxing you've only been boxing the last
eight weeks but now if you take any girl
off the streets you're probably gonna
mash them up 100 just in literally eight
weeks and I just I just think what am I
going to be like in my second fight my
third fight I'm going to smash this girl
up on April 22nd I'm very confident
about that and then the fight in June
and the fight in August and my my skills
my eye care just gonna Skyrocket because
everything I do in my life I like to put
100 in I've seen quite a lot of
controversy online as well about you
what's the lady's name that you're
fighting Julie Julie yeah you seem to
not you don't like each other that much
have you ever actually met before we
have we had a Face-Off at the launch
event yeah so the way it worked is we
had no idea who we were fighting it was
a live draw
um so I literally picked her name out of
a out of a hat basically and I drawed
her we did a Face-Off and at the start
the the trash talk as it were it was
obviously like you know for media and
then she started to get a bit personal
with me and started offending me what
was the most offensive thing that she
said
um I have no self-respect for myself and
have no respect for women and for me
that's very offensive coming from a very
dark place you know she doesn't know my
story she doesn't know me and to judge
me on such a personal level like that so
I'm flying out to Brazil on Monday to
meet her I'm gonna go meet her
interesting I'm gonna go rock up at a
gym are you pretty confident you're
gonna win there
I'm very confident what makes you so
confident because like presumably she's
going to be training hard as well what
makes you so confident you're going to
win because number one I've put in 110
in every single day I've got a full-time
training schedule you know I'm training
with the best of the best Leon Edwards
the UFC Champions boxing coach is my
coach I live with an MMA world champion
I'm in the best gym in the country and
also as well she's a bodybuilder and I
don't know if people know like
bodybuilders aren't boxers you know
she's very muscular she's going to Tire
really quickly so and you're fit and I'm
fit like you were skipping fast you know
I didn't even know there was such thing
as double and triple skips I just
thought skipping was skipping but I was
watching skip I was like damn yeah we
had five rounds together I was putting
pressure on you and then you were with
Akon straight afterwards borrowing Akon
So yeah you're very fit what's next then
after this are you gonna you're gonna
fight again or is this like a one thing
Challenge and then you're gonna move
back onto your businesses I mean I'm
loving this box and stuff so I want to
win this tournament and there's some
other potential you know promotions that
I could go on and do but um alongside
that you know I do want to carry on with
my businesses and and push property a
little bit more as well yeah talk about
that talk about how we met and and
you've done you've done some of our
training and you've got started in
property you sold your first deal and
you've got some rent to rent some
different things I know the focus now is
your fight but talk a little bit about
how we met and what made you want to get
into property with acon so I always
wanted to invest but when I think
thought of investing I thought crypto
and when I thought of crypto I thought
of like oh my God these people just like
put all their money in and lose their
money and then I thought about property
and I always thought you know property
you need to have hundreds of thousands
of pounds to invest and then we came
across you on YouTube we just started
watching you became completely inspired
more so for like as well I felt like
connected to you in a way because of the
sort of person you are like you're very
genuine you give off a really good vibe
and then I saw that you did like a crash
course that was a pound and me and a
couple like screw it we're going to go
turned up at your crash course
completely inspired wanted to learn more
we were like
so excited we literally saw our future
like in your hands from that day and
then we went on to do the Advanced
Training so we did the four day course
in was it Heathrow yeah like about a
month or so back now yeah it wasn't too
long and um you taught us all these
different creative strategies of like
how to get deals
um how to make money passively which is
a big thing for me because I don't have
a lot of time on my hands so for me an
investment you know it needs to be
passive and in that course we actually
sold five deals using your Knowledge and
Skills oh that's Madness gave us a
challenge of like we had an hour to
secure as many viewings as we can yeah
and acorn and I really wanted to get
into like rent to rent because we loved
the idea of like passive income that day
we secured five rent to rents and we
also sold a deal so we we had already
come to our event we did some of your
online training and we already came to
our event with a deal that we had
secured and we saw that deal with at the
at the course that's awesome man there
we go high five amazing and presumably
when you make a load of money on your
fight you're going to be putting at
least some of it back 100 what's your
plan then to be property what's the uh
what's the plan
for acorn and obviously we're partnering
with it together I would love to get
into the service accommodation but for
acorn and night it does need to be
passive so I have a key turn investment
so we will probably work with some deal
sources and get some deal sources to
secure us and set us up some deals so we
have like a passive income through
property and then we would love to go on
to do you know bras and start building
up a portfolio for our future I remember
as well when I first met you and acon so
I was I was talking about the importance
of sales and I said that every business
every job everything all boils down to
sales 100 I said for example someone
tell me like you and I pointed at you
and I said what do you do for a living
and Akon said strippers and I was like
oh okay and then it just completely
threw me I was thinking so so you guys
you fight and you're in property and
your influencers but you also we do
everything so acorn acorn is a stripper
okay so acorn's an MMA fighter he's a
good looking guy yep so honestly you've
got it flaunted on a Saturday night
he'll go down he does he does a tour so
it's actually like a computer so he's a
dancer MMA fighter he did some modeling
and stuff and myself I do like the
influence side of things content
creation I like being funny online and I
also do only fans as well so with that
comes a lot of marketing and how does
what do you think about only fans then
like does it does it raise eyebrows
amongst your family and friends and
stuff or is it do you think it's quite
acceptable or normal 100 do you know
what there's always going to be a stigma
around it but at the end of the day I'm
very big on self-love body empowerment
and expressing yourself and I feel like
for me on mine personally it's a way for
me to express myself right and you can
make money with it as well do you make
good money on any fans really good how
much money did you make on anything life
changing money is it I've been doing it
for a year and my first year I made 300
000. that's crazy yeah that's crazy yeah
so did you do it for the money or did
you do it because you find it empowering
both of course yeah but for me it's kind
of it's quite passive as well because
once you've set it up and you schedule
your content you make your content it's
completely passive and does icon do it
only fans as well he does yeah and does
he make good money not as good as me
so where does where does the fire come
from it's the goal the end goal and it's
the fire and it's the wheel like I'm in
it to win it you know what I mean like
I'm not I'm not in it actually in it for
the money and the the fame the this that
I'm generally in it because I want to be
the best and I want to put 110 in and
prove to myself more than anything that
I can do it and it does take a lot like
I listen to motivational speeches all
the time I manifest I'm a big Manifesto
I feel like I've manifested my whole
life so I manifest every day and well
you've done super well thank you so much
I'm gonna be there you're going to be
ring sized yeah I'm bringing Russell
with me my brother once I win jump in
the ring with me I'll jump in man do it
and you're gonna be wearing Samuel
leaves Merchant brand with sponsors 100
talk to me a little bit about Kingpin
because they're quite huge aren't they
they're saying that this is going to be
the biggest potential YouTube biggest
YouTube boxing tournament in the world
that's a big statement to make and
they're spending crazy money on this so
talk to me a little bit about Kingpin
and what they're doing and how how
they're promoting this so Kingpin our
YouTube boxing promotion that have got
the biggest YouTubers from all across
the world in together to do this
tournament there's eight guys eight
girls all coming in to fight for the
Kingpin title they have literally pumped
so much money and put so much effort
into marketing they've got a filming
crew filming for a Netflix documentary
the biggest guy on it has 150 million
subscribers on YouTube like it is a big
event damn how many people do you think
will watch millions millions from all
over the world Americans because I was
like this could be huge and you know
having like the merch and stuff just to
be a part of it yeah yeah and also you
invested in our training so I like to
invest in people that are investing so I
thought you know what when you when you
mentioned what you're doing I thought
yeah you know I think this will be a
good fit do you think acon was a little
bit afraid when he was sparring me do
you think a little as part of it you've
got them
Rob's going down well super proud of
what you're doing and I can't wait to
thank you so much and I really
appreciate you supporting me all the way
how do people get in touch if they want
to watch the fight or if they want to
get in touch with you how do they or
they want to check you out and only fans
maybe oh yeah Link in my Instagram
Instagram buyer you can find everything
there
um on my Tick Tock there's also the link
there amazing um or the Kingpin website
if you want to watch the ppv as they can
get down to Wembley on the April 22nd
April 22nd let me smash your face in
next week we'll be watching and we will
be there I'll be in person well done
keep up the good work thank you so much
I really appreciate it
[Music]
thank you